good morning John I am still excited
about pizza this is all very exciting
except for your mustache which is not
exciting at all but you know who I'm not
as excited as this guy oh my god I
consider myself to be something of an
expert in the genres of viral videos
there's there's lots of them there's
epic cute and epic wins epic fails epic
weirdness for me as a viewer the most
pure and rewarding kind of viral video
is the epic excitement beautiful
unabashed uncontrolled excitement it's
such a wonderful feeling that just
watching other people have it makes me
feel wonderful
John today I want to be stupid excited
about the very idea of excitement Matt
we're gonna start out with Rachel nedra
whose voice you may have heard in a
couple of Skrillex songs among many
other things and what I'm sure is a full
and complete life rachel has
competitively stacked cuts not sure how
difficult this is I'm not sure how
amazing it is it certainly looks amazing
and impressive but her reaction is the
thing I'm here for now let's look at the
video we started this video with this
guy loves trains I've been waiting for
this moment for months and it's finally
here look at that in 1953 next we have
alexandr gam who's hiking across the
Antarctic and you're doing this so you
don't have to carry your supplies the
whole way you leave some of your
supplies and caches along the way so you
can pick them up on the way back and in
his final cache after surviving on what
I assume is not the tastiest food in the
world he discovers that he has left some
treats yeah yeah
ah yeah I mean he put those cheese
doodles there didn't he know what to
expect I guess he forgot that it was
just the most surprising bag of Cheez
doodles of all time and surprise it
seems to be a part of it not knowing
what the outcome is and then finding
indeed that there is more example there
was another historic engine on the back
of that other engine then the guy got
even more excited you know it's appeal
to to the SNC sometimes it's amazing to
see people get excited about things that
you just don't understand why they're so
excited but yes yes I feel it too other
times you're right there with that
person like I'm willing to bet there are
a lot of people who wish they might be
able to like grow up and become Luke
Skywalker actually becoming a hero in
the Star Wars saga not something that
happens to bear in many people and
thanks to some foresight and the
internet we get to be there with John
boyega as he sees the Star Wars teaser
trailer and the part that he plays in it
yes finally this list would not be
complete without the most famous
Internet excited guy of all time
Yosemite bears he comes across a double
rainbow that has become through the
magic of the internet and the work of
the Gregory Brothers legendary double
rainbow all the way across the sky
sometimes it feels like the only moment
when it's culturally acceptable to feel
that kind of uncontrolled excitement is
in sporting events I'm not really into
sports me the last time I felt like that
level of excitement and just couldn't
control myself was in 2012 when the
Curiosity rover definitely was safe on
the surface of Mars I realize they'll
watch these clips is that there is so
much to be excited about if people are
open to the beauty and amazingness of
nature and of human accomplishment and
of their own accomplishments they're
kind of my heroes I want to be more like
them it's got a funny but I feel like it
requires work to say to myself don't
shut it down love things by yourself or
with others and without fears videos for
me are a masterclass in being open to
the wondrousness of nature and of the
human condition and of the self so I put
them in a playlist in the description
below you can click on it and watch all
of them and it's just a wonderful thing
to do John I'll see you tomorrow
I'm freaking my dog out
screaming bad need to make a video and
I'm gonna scream during it so just lay
down and just assume that I'm doing
human things that are weird